فنانه نشات في عائله فنيه تعشق الطرب
الاصيل
بعده لهجات عربيه واجنبيه وقدمت حفلات عده
اضافه لعدد من الاغاني المصوره فيديو كليب
ضايفتنا الفنانه اللبنانيه ناتاشا اثرت
البومه الاول عام 2010 والبوم الاخر
باللهجه الخليجيه من اشهر اغانيها باللهجه
المصريه ايوه وتصادف الايام اما باللهجه
الخليجيه اغاني داويني والله لا يبلانا
ولا تحرف كما لها عده اغاني باللهجه
العراقيه باغنيه الغرام التي تخطط 29
مليون مشاهده على موقعك يوتيوب
على احساس الحلو
الله يا عيني يا سلام
يا الله ما اجمله
كثير من الاغاني السعوديه منها الجديد
ومنها الاغاني الشعبي شو اكثر اغنيه قربتك
للجمهور السعودي اول اغنيه عملتها داوني
هي اكثر شيء
بداياته
وبعدها لليوم بتنطلب مني بحفلاته وبكل
الاشياء اللي بالنشاطات الفنيه اللي بيقوم
فيها وطبعا من بعدها في كثير ناس ما بتعرف
انه الخاتم يماني هي اغنيه الخاصه
يعني كثير فنانين
ولا تحرف اخر اغنيه لك كانت موجوده يلي
هلا عم تحطوها عم تسمعها ما هو سر كثر
الطلب احيائك للحفلات الخاصه والاجتماع
انا حدا يلي ما بيعرفني اكيد اهل الاعراس
وزوجات يلي بتحبوني بعرفهم اكثر انا حدا
كثير اون تايم ااه بس كون بالزواج او
بالحفلات بعامل اهل الزواج
من اغانيه يعني اكيد بتغني اغاني خاصه
حبيبه قلبي الفنانه احلام ام فهد اكيد
برجعلها تحيه كثير كبيره اول شيء بقولكم
انه انا بحبك يا انسانه لانه انسانه
انسانيتها عاليه جدا يلي ما بيعرفها شخصيا
عنجد بيجهلها اييه دعمتني ببداياتي وبعدها
لليوم تدعمني ودعمتني اكثر شيء باخر اغنيه
لالي لا تحرف
وجودك معانا صباح العربيه لا تتحفينا
باغنيه من اغانيك
تفضل
[موسيقى]
ولا تقولني بربك
شيء ما قلت
[موسيقى]
ها كل ما دورت
فرحك وانت هاجر ارجع من دمع اليدين
لاجلك عمل
[موسيقى]
ته من عرفتك يا
منسيني السعاده
ما عرفت الفرحه
فين كده كل ما حاولت اقول لك ما احبك قلت
شكلك نووي القلب بعاد